[Applause]
a two-day debate in the Anglican
Church's Parliament
is in favor please show
those against
but it's an issue that's been wrangled
over for years we've spent decades uh
even trying to argue for the church to
say anything positive in a corporate way
about same-sex relationships today was
that day today General Synod said and
affirmed there is good in same-sex
relationships this is part of God's good
creation and for me that's a wonderful
first step for the first time ever the
Church of England says same-sex couples
will be publicly unreservedly and
joyfully welcomed inside of the church
it now means that same-sex couples can
have their ceremonies blessed but they
still won't be able to get married
inside of the church itself
the Church of England is under No
Illusion there are deep Anglican
divisions on the issue not just in this
country but around the world where
consequences can be grave
I'm genuinely torn by this
the difference is we have here
are small compared to those
with many around the communion
this isn't just about listening to the
rest of the world it's caring
let's just be clear on that it's about
people who die
women who'll be raped
children who'll be tortured
and a proposal intended to put an end to
Decades of disagreements has instead
exposed deep-rooted disparities the
number of us voted against because we
don't think it's possible to keep
everybody happy you can't say that a
certain pattern relationships is blessed
on the one hand but at the same time say
it doesn't contravene the the current
teaching of the church
although the motion was passed there are
still terms that need to be finalized in
a proposal that's gone too far for some
and not far enough for others Sherman
Freeman Powell Sky News